and seen that's it ladies and gentlemen
that is a wrap good job people can't
wait for the world to see our horror
movie with its symbolic plot and
ambiguous ending the Internet is gonna
be debating this one for years of this
if your film is vague and dreary
prepared yourself for a theory no no it
was meant to be artistic hello internet
welcome to film Theory the show that
delves so deeply into crackpot fan
theories it's scary
and today we're partnering up with
TV to poke around their twisted universe
if you're unfamiliar with TV it is
pretty miraculous actually if we're
being honest in this YouTube age you've
churn it out as fast as you can while
keeping it so brand safe it hurts
TV is like the complete opposite of all
of those things and proves that you can
still succeed on this platform even when
the algorithm is actively stacked
against you each TV upload is a
mini horror movie full of practical
effects horrific original monsters and
scares lots of scares gory
edge-of-your-seat
scary like you just don't see this sort
of stuff anymore on YouTube most
definitely but heck even in theaters
original monster designs practical
effects it's crazy Crypt TV is just a
breath of fresh air so if you like
scares and you're gonna love this
channel and you're gonna love being
subscribed to them go do it right now in
fact I'll be here talking about their
universe and get this crypt is still not
done not only have they crafted hundreds
of original creepy tales that you could
just watch for free right now but
they've gone one step further they've
created an entire interconnected
Cinematic Universe yeah eat your heart
out Universal Studios where's your dark
universe now between Crypt TVs various
properties such as the birch or Deo camp
monster and Sonny family cult they've
pretty much created the Avengers for
scary monsters why today we're focusing
on the team's Ironman a faceless
creature known
the look see not only is he one of the
most recurring monsters in the crib TV
Cinematic Universe he's also one of the
most intriguing since season 1 fans have
been speculating wildly who is the look
see what exactly is it up to and why and
now that we're at the end of season 2
were left with an even bigger question
why are there suddenly two of them
getting to the bottom of it all in one
video would surely be a fool's errand
but fortunately for you at home I am
that fool trust me if you don't stick
around for this one you're gonna regret
it as will soon come to learn regrets
come with a price let's dive in we start
with the basics there's very little
that's explicitly told to us about who
the looks he is and how he operates in
his videos most of the information comes
in the form of a cryptic letter that he
leaves for all of his victims if you
yourself cannot release it will come to
take a piece and when he says he's gonna
take a piece he means literally and that
piece is very frequently not tiny
throughout each season we get to see the
bloody consequences of this little
mantra if a person is unable to let go
of something or someone in their life a
past marriage
a loss of child a failed business
what-have-you the looksie will come to
literally make that cut for you
season 1 explores the fallout of a
mysterious poisoning which killed 13
students at high school full season 2 is
a prequel story taking place back in the
1930s following the families of two twin
brothers Robert and James Capshaw who
made the mistake of founding a bank
right before the Great Depression
whoopsy as you can imagine both
scenarios offer plenty of opportunity
for the Luxy to uh help people in
dealing with their grief and remorse so
the look sea monster appears to have
himself a basic set of killing rules
that he follows not all that hard
right but it's a bit more nuanced than
it first appears first it's important to
know that your goodness or badness of a
person doesn't seem to matter to him in
season 2 we watch as the look-see lets a
sociopathic killer escape unharmed
because this killer named Raymond who
wait a minute I know that sociopathic
killer that's my buddy James a Jenice
from dead meat
look at you buddy chalk up a kill count
a one for you luckily for James though
he has no regrets about his horrific
murder and therefore has nothing to
release and is thus let go by the
monster his thief buddies however who
art
so sure about the attack that's taking
place suffer the consequences we also
know that the look see doesn't just work
alone select humans are forced to become
his mindless helpers for instance season
ones Jenny survives the look sees first
attack and when she still refuses to
release the regrets over a bad marriage
bill looks he returns this time though
she not only releases she fights back
and the looks he makes her his new
helper
I mean someone has to write all those
creepy notes can't be expected to do it
on its own what if he breaks a nail
these human helpers though aren't immune
to the look-sees attacks if they get in
the way of his plans well they're
suddenly on the chopping block in season
Wanda looks he attacks his own human
helper when he interferes with his plan
for killing the cop finally there's the
case of the pocket watch the look-see
outside of being a snappy dresser
wearing hobo gloves also has himself the
classy monsters accessory of a pocket
watch this watch appears to be able to
manipulate time and seems to be tied to
his helpers the watch pauses when his
season 1 helper decides to pursue other
career options and then it resumes once
Jenny is hired in his place in the
hospital but the biggest pocket watch
surprise comes at the end of season 2
when a new look-see manages to emerge
from it
obviously this prompts so many questions
why is the second look-see being birthed
before our very eyes where did it come
from why is it coming out of a watch and
what's with that cute little bow on its
head in the shadow those answers sadly
just don't exist or at least they don't
exist in the look-see series remember
Crypt TV is a connected universe and by
broadening out our search and taking our
own little look-see at other in universe
crypt TV properties we can piece
together more about what's really going
on here we begin by looking at season 3
of the sunny family cult which tells the
story of a teenager named a tailor
trying to live a normal life despite her
not so normal family of serial killing
cultists talk about awkward season 3
focuses on the character Roger as he
tries to get Taylor to carry out a
demonic ritual from an ancient evil tome
that seems kind of redundant doesn't it
is there ever such a thing as at home in
movies that isn't both ancient and evil
where did all the good wholesome new
tomes go anyway this isn't just any old
evil book it's the one upon which the
entire crypt universe is built
considering it's connected to most of
the other crypt TV properties like in
more Dayo when these Scouts try to get
their demonic rune decoding badge so
much easier than that knot-tying badge
anyway when Roger opens up the tome and
Sonny family we see the look sea
creature has his own two-page spread
along with other Crypt TV monsters like
a pony and the birch there's even a page
that describes the ritual for creating
these sorts of monsters calling for a
blood sacrifice of four victims then the
fifth will quote become something
thanks for the specificity their book
I'm going to the trouble of finding four
human sacrifices the least you could do
is offer me some assurances that the
fifth one's gonna turn into something
cool and not you know sack of lentils
that's honestly the lamest thing I could
think of fun sitting here recording
anyway the picture strongly suggests
that the some things we're talking about
means one of the monsters from the Crypt
TV universe now this is a huge point
because it sheds light upon a couple
central tenants of the Crypt TV universe
ten at number one there are monsters
throughout the universe and humans can
turn into monsters ten at number two
just because there's one particular
monster running around doesn't mean
there can't be more of that exact same
type of monster someday for example say
there's one looksie running around the
city of harbor any moment ritual could
be performed and a second look-see could
join the frame the tome also explains
that an order for the ritual to work the
fifth sacrifice must be performed by a
girl of seventeen with dark hair dark
eyes and violence edged into her soul
this is precisely why Roger sought out
Taylor and Sonny family season three and
just like Roger planned at the
ceremonial steps are completed at
season's end with Taylor takes the fifth
and final victim but twist that victim
is Roger himself just like the tome said
in the final frames of season three we
see his body come back to life
supposedly beginning the transformation
into something what exactly that
something is is left unclear the point
is that sunny family offers a detailed
explanation of how monsters like the
look-see come into existence five deaths
with the fifth one being performed by a
young woman and at the end of look see
season 2 we see the birth of a second
look sea monster so naturally that begs
the question was that blue gloved bow
headed creature born out of the exact
same ritual we just talked about in
sunny family cult all signs point to yes
looksies a season to body count at the
Capshaw homestead is you guessed it five
the Father James the two thieves William
and Thomas his wife Mary and finally
their son David and a season to have a
young woman with violence edged into her
sould I could have committed the fifth
and final blood sacrifice well that's a
big Olli up to its Lea Capshaw herself
the look sees human helper who seems
relatively unconcerned about the plight
of her family true Lea appears to be
younger than 17 and her hair and eyes
aren't particularly dark but demonic
rituals work in strange ways
maybe the tomes writers were just
getting a little bit too specific
sometimes you're looking for someone
with five years experience on the job
when all you really need is someone with
a can-do attitude in this case maybe
it's less we need a dark featured
teenage girl and more he'll take any
young violent girl all applications
welcome plus the streak she makes across
David's face and her little family
murder drawing his red different color
than the streets that she puts across
the eyes of her other family members
something tells me that that drawing is
gonna wind up on any refrigerators but
could this mean that his death is
somehow different more special it's very
reminiscent of the fifth sacrifice from
the tome which has red ink displayed on
the fifth of victims chest
if leah was indeed the one who killed
her brother David it would explain one
key logical inconsistency with the end
of season 2 of look see why David got
himself killed despite the fact that he
does in fact release prior to the
look-sees attack you see David's grief
is around the loss of his younger
brother theodore teddy' Capshaw
represented by the teddy bear that he
carries around however we see him
actively rip apart the bear prior to his
death and yet he still somehow dies
anyway sure it seems like the doings of
the looksie but remember David's death
occurs
camera so the identity of his killer is
completely unknown we've only ever see
the looks he kill people for two reasons
either a they failed to release or be
they obstructed his efforts to kill
people who failed to release David did
neither of these things so it doesn't
make a lot of sense for the looksie to
kill him but if Lia killed him David's
death wouldn't be a violation of
look-sees own killing rules and would
also explain why we see a second
look-see appear at the end of the season
but where things really start to get
suspicious is when you start looking a
bit closer at the details for instance
five death sequences happen over and
over again in the look-see series season
two starts with four deaths and then the
death of Theodore a young boy with dark
eyes dark hair and a shockingly similar
fashion sense to the look seed same
shirt same blazer same lack of tie and
open collar that makes for ten deaths
total in season two two sets of five and
at the end of the season we've got
ourselves two separate look CDs
coincidence maybe but now consider this
the look-see creation ritual may have
taken place in season one as well
discounting the 13 poisoning deaths that
start off the season with the body count
in season 1 again appears to be 5 Jenny
who was arguably sacrificed and then
brought back to life in the watch stops
Raymond the look sees first helper
Arlene the mistress Daniel the cheating
husband and finally the grieving father
Jonathan and again wouldn't you know it
but the fifth victim's death occurs off
screen and with a dark-haired dark-eyed
young girl left in the vicinity in this
case the ghost of Camille the daughter
that Jonathan is mourning a character
who's only on screen for a matter of
seconds yet is somehow important enough
to be featured on the look-see poster
stream and one other thing I'd like to
point out about Camille remember that
bow on look-see to Plato's head might
that be related to the bow that we see
on Camille's head which is also perhaps
the ribbon that Jonathan picks up off
the floor in the closet which is also
the bow the look-see takes after killing
Jonathan true the events of season 1 do
indeed occur after the events of season
2 but remember the look see has himself
a very powerful timepiece a timepiece
that very notably ticks back
but ok enough random observations here
it's time to start narrowing this down
into some theories first up Fyodor
Capshaw aka teddy there are several
reasons to believe that this is the kid
who would one day turn into the red
glove - look see 1.04 one thing
Theodore's death is quite possibly the
fifth death in chronologically the first
five death sequence that we see in the
series secondly the jacket and shirt
that we see him wearing aren't identical
to the look see one point it was outfit
right down to that unbuttoned collar
thirdly well he himself may not have
been killed by a girl with dark hair and
dark eyes you don't really know for sure
he himself has dark hair and dark eyes
which may be the starting point for that
whole element of the ritual in the first
place fourth there's a clear theme to
all of look-sees season two killings
greed the father is a greedy banker the
thieves want to steal from him the wife
values her pearls now we know look seas
are motivated by giving people a chance
to release their regrets their pettiness
the guilt that they have on their lives
potential victims that ultimately
embrace what's really important family
or loved ones ultimately survive the
look-sees attack therefore it would make
sense that Teddy Capshaw a kid whose
mother and father literally loved their
possessions more than him would come
back with this sort of killing ethos he
was ignored to the point of death he
won't allow that to happen to anyone
else and finally a fifth point in
Teddy's favor both his brother David and
his mother Mary have memories of Teddy's
standing in a field or in a farmhouse
not in New York City where they're
returning from this suggests that the
Capshaw's were returning to their former
home in harbor not moving there at
random in the wake of the Great
Depression this would explain why the
look sea haunts Harbor it's the location
where Teddy died next let's consider
Camille from season 1 there are a
handful of reasons to believe that
Camille became the new blue glove to
look c 2.0 first just as theodore was
the object of david's grief in season 2
Camille is the object of her father
Jonathan's grief in season 1 with bolt
winding up as the fifth deaths in
respective five death sequences secondly
look c 2.0 appears to have a bow on its
head
just as camille had a bow on hers third
the blue look see emerges from a pocket
watch that's ticking backwards this
could mean that the blue look C is from
the future meaning the blue look C could
very well be Camille who forced drowned
decades after the events of season 2 and
lastly there's that poster connection
Camille is a super minor character of
the first season and yet there she is
featured prominently in the marketing
for the series it's almost as if they're
teasing that she's gonna have a bigger
role to play in all of this or it's just
an elaborate ruse captain phasma was
featured on a couple of Star Wars
posters and we see how important she was
regardless one thing that we can be sure
of is that there are now at least two
look-sees running around the crib TV
universe will there be more in the
future who knows but one thing is
definitely clear human helper Jenny has
given herself writers cramp with all the
letters she's preparing meaning there's
a lot more to come but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cuts
you